welcome to this video round 10 action of
the candidates and we have an important
game here to look at Ireland the leader
of the tournament with plus three score
playing against Mammadyarov with some
one fifty percent which doesn't sound
like a big difference but ok with the
direct win magyar would come into
striking distance and he certainly ask
momentum after beating aronian in the
last round with a fine game so let's see
what what's happens here are not playing
efore yeah his usual move but it's also
the move that he normally plays as weird
as it sounds if he wants to play with
the draw in hand and yeah it's a it's
it's in a way often like that that with
one before you can get better you you if
you if you are content with the game of
of two results before sometimes a pretty
good choice if you know your your theory
ok a six then I Dorf already played
before in this tournament by Mammadyarov
and against tom de boeuf he had played
this so Alan could certainly expect the
opening certainly very fighting choice
trying to unbalance the game and of
course are not displaying the new night
of mainline h3 just joking here but it's
a the move that they all play here and
again ok it has given a vishie a very
important victory against Apollo so why
not repeat it yaya playing e6 ego sum
here misc sets up evening and livening
information just like to polish it but
now plays it a bit differently here to
palo had played the
voluntary retreat to d7 which isn't
terribly bad or anything but I'm a girl
plays age 69 which I think makes lots of
sense to for the moment to stop the
white pawns and yeah white continues to
develop visual g2 there should be three
are logical moves and now f4 yeah the
white also i could play Queen d2 here
first I mean in general white certainly
wants to move the Queen somewhere to d2
or 2 e 2 and then casts a long then f4
probably later um it's a it's a matter
of move order here I guess if you play
Queen d2 i'm not sure that the queen is
so well placed there if you look at a
move like that yeah you probably need to
move again and here and maybe black can
even go for g5 this is very often an
interesting motif to block a for one
moment and establish a strong knight on
d5 anyway Queen d2 is not very useful
you can look at Queenie to in comparison
this also was an alternative maybe now
maybe takes and be 54 like something
like that it might be possible no I
don't know many many possibilities are
not played f4 immediately gaining this
space in the center and this is in a way
the most ambitious move certainly if
black now tries to yeah we release more
relief of some pressure by taking then
you can actually take in one go and then
Cass along with a good game yeah what
like what is blacks move actually here
it's not not that easy you cannot move
to be pawn it's not clear that you want
to put the Queen here he played a good
move i believe he played Knight to d7
enter this intense this somewhat
disturbing Bishop check and the night
probably has to move away anyway
some stage so an interesting way to play
Queen d2 now buy an island very normal
move of course and I found actually some
some examples of this position where
Knight f3 was played this is an
interesting way to play it covers the H
cross square so that this Bishop check
now is of course check of course
entirely pointless after coming long
castles black is almost busted him sewn
idea three is reflecting move against
this idea and white will simply play the
Queen to one of those squares and Castle
long this leads to a very typical
typically unbalanced this is solely in
middle games um there was what one funny
example that I could I could actually
show you not the complete game but just
just a couple of moves this was played
in a game um moon geun to will move into
were against humpy koneru the one of the
top female players moon geun to will is
also female play if i'm not mistaken at
the time she was only rated 2200
something in Cornero 2600 and white
after before played 95 and got a vicious
attack to meet canerro overcoming a
rating difference of more than 300
points quite quite nice but that that
actually happens rather often and the
sicilian that the better player playing
black is losing to an attack you very
often winning this so Yin has the better
player but you need to accept the
occasional loss where the other side is
just throwing the kitchen sink at you
and meet you yeah 190 of three was an
interesting alternative but Queenie to
is perfectly all right of course yeah
now the capture and e5 a very direct
solution that number
off as you can see basically blitzed out
yet obviously prepared all that takes
check and now the check very interesting
yeah of course white cannot play with
the king and the center so Bishop f2
must be played and now 19 so we've seen
a very quick transformation in this
position Black has managed to play e5
exchanging a 4f porn and this is led to
a very very defined structure where
black has an excellent piece on e5
really fantastic piece this night and he
manages to get off those bishops so we
can put those moves on the board and
even miss should be six so this is a
very very instructive type of structure
black ass as mentioned a great PCM he
has a nicely anchored bishop on e6 is
always protected by the f7 point cannot
be attacked easily so is this actually a
very good position for black yeah black
is certainly fine but he also has got
some some deficits and in the position
and this is of course the g6 porn very
often the d6 porno backward porn in the
Sicilian it's not a real problem um
because yeah sometimes you have this
supposedly bad bishop on your seven but
yeah bad bishops protect good pawns this
fun figure of speech is true quite often
on here the d6 porn needs to be covered
by by by heavy pieces mostly the Queen
in this first instance and we see that
after Queen d4 with the direct attack
check like went for long castles to keep
the pawn protected yeah rook the eighth
if you don't want to cancel long you can
play but after Queen a form it's a bit
awkward what are you doing now this is
something you don't want to see as
like getting you into trouble yeah you
probably need to play something what you
don't want now our King move this is a
double attack lon castles is really the
best move that's pretty clear yeah and
this means black always has to watch out
for pressure against the pawn and with
the King on the queenside you of course
have slumped some problems with your
King position it is slightly weakened
white can always at the moment it's not
leading to anything Queen a seven up for
just for argument's sake what can I can
trap her the old queen but it's not
helping anything Queen it out but in
general of the King position is slightly
weakened and of course in this structure
while black has the great square and if
I white also as a good square on d5 the
difference is of course that the knight
on d5 is completely unassailable but on
d5 a night that might appear there can
very often simply be captured and if
white is forced to capture with the pawn
this is normally not helping him very
much okay it activates the bishop but
it's a yeah it's a good compensation for
other deficits this d 5 square and it's
a very logical now the player believe
Bishop f1 makes lots of sense the bishop
on g2 is just looking at the own porn
and and once the possible the in the
distant future wants to have this
sacrificial ideas or simply regroup the
bishop and we see some of those ideas
later yeah Quincy five now by
Mammadyarov he certainly would love a
queen trait if you just look at this if
white would trade which is a serious
mistake then this slight weakness on d6
has now transformed into a healthy c5
porn which might even might even support
please come into D for the night
obviously the prime candidate for that
this would be very nice so honored
cannot exchange Queen g3 simply yeah
they got this repetition in and honored
certainly is fine with the draw I mean
he's in such a comfortable position I
believe I actually believe if he would
if he manages to draw the rest of the
games he were qualified I'm very very
sure about that i mean how it's it's
simply the only for me the only real
scenario is someone beating him and
being the guy who catches up with them
and have the better try break this could
have been Kramnik is still playing him
kayaking is playing him and sevilla is
playing him those those players said to
Paolo theoretically speaking but his he
does not have the points really to catch
up with anna laughter yet lost her the i
had already a bit into part of i'm sorry
about that yeah well it's an uncertainty
okay with the draw let's put it that way
ok King b8 Normandy are off wants to
continue not Queenie five again but ok
watch is a useful moves to play put the
knife down no see 3 yeah this is a very
very safe setup and white has ideas I'm
actually to improve him if you give
white a couple of moves you can imagine
that this Bishop not a very great piece
at the moment right even come let's say
you play the rook somewhere you can
actually put this on the board it was
played and then many intend to this
regrouping even if you imagine in this
position just for argument's sake that
light square bishops would be exchanged
then what is having some advantage it's
not like fantastic but it's great it
would be great achievement for white 2 2
a 2
exchange going because then your knight
on d5 is also not in any way yeah like a
not ever exchange it or anything and
then white could try to do something
actually so this is an idea get the
light squared Bishop sixth gyuki one or
very normal moves roop the 80 hours of
the deform and our Bishop e3 was played
initiating the dimensioned idea yeah n
turn here Mammadyarov plate 96 attacking
the rook rook c4 and now play to create
a seven and offer the draw mm-hmm okay
uhm Jung I'm not quite sure what to make
of that I mean they only can make a draw
by agreement after move 30 so this is
exactly move 30 and I didn't see the
press conference would have been
interesting to to learn what they
thought about about the position um
maybe mum a jar of 40 he is in slide
trouble I mean it's possible he actually
would have needed to win it i think to
to have a fair chance to to to do
something in this tournament but ok yeah
how to how to assess the position it's
white smooth and i understand that are
not just accepted the draw it's not like
white has anything substantial and from
a tournament perspective draws perfectly
ok i think probably bishop t2s white
smooth a bishop c2s wats move to to get
this ideas in that i mentioned bishop to
be three or maybe under the right
circumstances you can also put it on a
form could be a another idea yeah i'm
not so sure what black should do here
there there are some slight slight
problems I
I understand that if you attack the rook
again for example going back here let's
just son and I don't need to draw here
and then I have those ideas as mentioned
yeah maybe black is is a bit
uncomfortable as possible the computer
gives it as completely equal and nothing
much happening but maybe he thought he
is in slight slight trouble one problem
from the black point of us and that the
Queen does not have any squares and you
can of course get this night of the
board if you like but this obviously
would give white lots of scope for the
bishop it could easily be a go to f5
possibly to e6 always controlling the c8
square and then white might even think
about the porn advance if it is right
rightly times advancing with the points
after some various or preparation
however yeah maybe you felt
uncomfortable and it's of course of
course mami gr would love to win
everything's great but using also means
it's completely over in the situation
now I'm if you compare both players
co-op plus three fifty percent his
chances are very very slim but yeah I
don't know maybe um maybe he should have
risked more years like I don't know it's
hard to tell but it's not a position
really that is anything brilliant for
black okay I draw agreed everything's
still looking great for the former
former world champion the Shilin
together yeah almost you can call it a
return match against them against magma
Scotland real well this is another game
my honor to didn't didn't make any any
mistakes or whatever look at some of the
other games there are really blunders
being committed and Anand hasn't
done any of those alright thanks for
watching